hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on new world again and
today is gonna be another blog post dev
talk kind of situation with the video
and it's gonna be about corrupted
breaches pretty much these are gonna be
the more PvE things that happen
throughout the world of a Turnham
there's gonna be a lot of these
happening the more you gain influence
and territory within the world the
Turnham the more powerful you are the
more powerful enemies spawn and as long
as you keep those bridges open the worse
it's going to get so let's read as it
says eternal is a land of immense beauty
and endless wonder that the corrupted
seek to stain and dominate with their
vile presence taking what was once
serene and peaceful and twisting it to
their will they will do this by ripping
open the ground and flooding the area
with corrupted creatures and structures
the very air turns into a thick black
smoke and all is illuminated by an evil
red glow pulsating with an unearthly
light these are known as corrupted
breaches as you establish a safe haven
in a settlement or fort the corrupted
take notice corrupted breaches will
begin to emerge in your territory making
travel and resource gathering more
difficult the longer these breaches go
unaddressed guarding these breaches are
the Acolytes of corruption like their
lesser brethren the cultists they
channeled the dark forbidden forces of
corruption to summon forth and sustain
the dread portals and monoliths that
formed the heart of corrupted breaches
their formidable adversaries capable of
quickly changing the tide of battle
levitating effortlessly across great
distances flinging deadbolts at melters
energy and conjuring explosive orbs of
pure corruption luckily there is a way
to destroyed these abominations you must
band together and clear out the enemies
protecting the beating heart of the
breach once the corrupted creatures have
been destroyed and as often few staff is
required to seal the breach
conquering a corrupted breach not only
cleanses your land of a dangerous threat
it also rewards you with some unique
resources found nowhere else in the game
but you must remain vigilant as
corrupted breaches won't remain closed
for very long the stronger you become
the more of the corruption will seek to
destroy you
it will open new and more powerful
breaches sweeping for the creatures of
impossible size and strength the
corrupted are relentless enemy and won't
stop the terror watch from the face of a
tournament so pretty much we got a
pretty
iein TLDR of what's gonna be happening
with these corrupted breaches now we're
gonna be going a bit more in depth in a
second on what those sizes and what
they're going to be in the differences
between some of them are but yeah pretty
much the main TLDR of it is that if
you're in a territory you're gaining a
lot of influence the more powerful your
influences within that area the more the
corrupted hate you because they don't
want that they want all the power on all
that influence so they're going to be
sending out more guys to face you and
you can either wait into your bunker and
wait until they eventually invade you or
you can go out and invade them and stop
it before it happens I'm assuming you
would rather want to stop it before it
happens because if they end up gathering
a bunch of different forces for a
corrupted breach invasion on your
property and your influence in your
territory there's gonna be a lot more
than if you just took them out one at a
time as they came in next up it says
adventuring a new world can be perilous
even on a good day but opening your
mouth will live to see territories
affected by corruption assuming in
you'll be able to clearly see indicators
showcasing the different corrupted
breaches spread throughout the territory
armed with this knowledge you'll be able
to plan out your path and if you'd like
to avoid these dangers or specifically
go after them
you can not all breaches are created
equally they come in varying degrees of
difficulty sighs and enemy defenders
some corrupted breaches can be managed
by a single player while others will
require a skilled combat of teams to
complete them make sure you're prepared
for the upcoming battle by crafting the
required as off staff and potions to
protect from the corrupted below are
some of the few examples of the
corrupted breaches you'll encounter
during your time and it turn them and in
the blog post they showed four versions
of these breaches ranging in size and
difficulty with actual some pictures I
could show you on screen first is the
corrupted monolith a very small which
looks like a very just enlarged kind of
gem in a sense it's a very low level but
that seems like there's going to be a
lot of them out in the world saying is
there very small probably not a whole
lot of people that are going to be
defending these things so probably just
a one person bike would be totally fine
and you could easily probably do this
solo next is the corrupted portals the
thing that we've been seeing a lot in
trailers before they are smaller but
they seem to be bringing a lot more
forces than the corrupted monoliths can
probably through that said portal mega
transport any kind of people they want
as
as it probably fit through that portal
next is the in festering Grove corrupted
as off as pooled underneath the earth
splitting the ground and rise to this
twisted monstrosity that you're seeing
on screen they will be a tougher fight
but there will probably be more enemies
and especially some tougher enemies in
specific so definitely watch out for
that one
and my personal favorite maybe because
it's the last one has to be the
festering hive a giant huge hive tower
that sprouted up in birth the corrupted
beings that are within the walls this is
giant the post that ends with the
sentence is saying sit behind your walls
until the corrupted eventually invade or
take the fight to them stealing back to
the depths from whence they came pretty
much saying that like I said before you
can either sit behind your walls and
wait for the corrupted to invade you or
you can go out and invade them and take
the fight to where they live yeah that
was pretty much what's going to be
happening with these corrupted breaches
and it's actually pretty exciting I
think it's going to be a really cool
interesting kind of combat situation
going on with the game I don't know too
many games that I haven't played a vast
range of mmo's in the past but I have
had my fair share of them and to my
knowledge there wasn't many of these
involved especially getting bigger and
bigger the more influence you have
avenge I mean in some games that I'd be
playing they're just still have those
low level ones that would be kind of
hard in the beginning but obviously you
got extremely powerful and they didn't
level up at all and you're just one
tapping everything and it really wasn't
that fun I believe this is going to be a
hell of a lot better yeah let me know if
you guys think about this stuff in the
comments below like the V if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new take care
guys have a great is today peace out let
me know what you think about the video
[Music]
you